let's consider the motion of a single
particle moving with the velocity V in a
ground reference frame say recall that
we defined the momentum of this object
as MV and we know that Newton's second
law can be written in terms of the
change of momentum dp/dt and when we
integrated newton's second law for
impulse causes the integral of DP from
some time T prime equals zero to some
time T so we're integrating T Prime and
here we're taking our momentum from some
initial momentum to some momentum at
time T we have that the impulse causes
the momentum of this single particle to
change and in particular this is what we
call impulse and if the impulse is zero
so as an example if the impulse F DT
prime equals zero that tells us that the
momentum of our particle has not changed
now let's consider our same thing for
angular momentum the only difference is
that we choose some point s and we'll
write the vector RS to where the object
is and our angular momentum we defined
about the point as was the vector from s
and we can indicate maybe to the mass M
so it's a vector from s to where the
object is located cross the momentum of
the object and this is how we define the
angular momentum and recall that our
basic concept is that the torque about s
causes the angular momentum about s to
change for this single particle now
torque is if there's a force acting on
the particle so for instance if the
force were acting at some angle not only
does the force change the book cause the
momentum to change but we know that if
there's a torque about s it will cause
the angular momentum of the particle to
change too now let's talk about the
angular
pulse which is integrating the torque
from say some time T prime equals zero
to some time T and that's the integral
of the angular momentum about s and now
we're integrating this from some initial
angular momentum to some final angular
momentum and just as before we have that
the angular impulse will result in a
change of angular momentum and in
particular if our angular impulse is
zero that implies that the angular
momentum of this particle is constant
and so you can see the analogies the
important fact to realize is that in the
reference frame momentum does not depend
on any point but our angular momentum
does depend on the choice of the point s
and in particular in terms of the
impulse the torque about S is also a
quantity that depends on s and so that's
the analogy between momentum of a single
particle and angular momentum of a
single particle